[Music]
in are you news yeah submitted by stands
out oh speaking of Chinese women
traveling to South Korea need plastic
surgery certificate
what do you mean speaking of Chinese oh
oh that stands out job oh I heard stands
out did the baby come out your [ __ ]
ears like what happened
maybe you just gotta work on your
pronunciation David could you be the
last person to talk to me about
they were so quick with the comeback
Julia makes a good bodyguard for the
girls yeah I love overshoes not just
David my son could be you at a distance
training for the Spartan Race Oh David
you are and I've been getting fatter so
I got a lot of cushion women traveling
to South Korea need plastic surgery
certificates to get back because they no
longer match their passport phone well
you can't cuz you you're going to a
different kind that you can't modify and
now your face looks different it's
positive surgery that gangster dude let
me tell you this though real quick
though y'all if you are ugly as [ __ ] and
you really really really want to change
your face get it in South Korea or a
country that has been doing it for years
and years and years because they could
do it in a way where you actually do
look like you were born that way looks
more natural what is a country other
than South Korea because the night yeah
I've heard in Mexico but I don't know if
that's good always a little half a lot
of things in life and you know if you
can't control your food for everything
like even when I was getting LASIK done
I don't wanna I wasn't trying to find
the doctor that just got out of med
school you know as always guys been
practicing for 10 years okay cool you
need like that in between though cuz if
they've been practicing for too long and
they're ancient
yeah it's also a cheaper out there to
compare yeah yeah compared to here
because it's so common I think so yes
okay like laser like it's so common in
like in la that we I mean that's where
we go that it's cheaper than what to
remove like what [ __ ] hair at arbitrary
[ __ ] Thank You just body hair we'll see
him all hair pervert what the [ __ ] they
do do you about how they'll see you
pretty close
is there a menu there is a menu you
think about butthole here yeah around
the rosey everybody two things happen
then or one of three things the first
one is either just told you about it the
second is you held the mirror and you
you you saw it or the third one is you
just stick your finger in your balls no
you have to do that the fourth one is
every time I wipe my ass there's [ __ ]
Chinese brushstroke calligraphy on it
you're making brush characters with your
toilet paper
why the [ __ ] there's a [ __ ] ancient
Chinese scroll come from he's hooked in
kanji on a napkin this will just [ __ ]
why is it oh how I apologize so there
was this photo that went viral on the
Chinese media site like their Weibo
Weibo Weibo yeah so it's this photo and
so they were seeming that these three
men women has aa woman the airport and
apparently they were denied monsters no
they look like the Japanese um Mike
spirited away yeah yeah the black
creatures with the mask they looked like
they got bee stings all over the place
you know
so this originally surfaced because
they're Chinese TV anchor tweeted out
saying that she came across these women
at the airport and that they were having
issues because their faces didn't match
their passports and they weren't able to
leave the country it makes sense but
then later out later on it came out that
that was just fake a lot of things what
is this picture real yeah well looks
like the picture is real but it seems
like the story behind it maybe I'm not
exactly sure
all I know is that there's reports that
that was fake news they got dressed in a
time machine they look like they were
dressed for school in 1950 from this
angle did look like nuns
one of them got Chuck Taylors on though
oh but those are all - that's our old
people can always wear chance another
weather Thomas Marty when the chucks
come out like 1940s they're like the
first basketball shoe ever why this dude
Chuck Taylor yeah you know what though I
like the little little basketball shorts
then a little a little I want to wear
little shorts so and you the story
behind this photo we don't know but what
we do know though is that these next
photos I want to show you they are real
before and after photos of passes
surgery and it shows that there was a
problem in South Korea of women not
matching their passport photos which led
to plastic surgeons now needing to thank
you they need to give certificates to
these patients in order for the the
people at the airport so they can know
like okay this is who they say they're
back in I thought you said that they're
gonna provide like a passport photo
service on the side well we can they're
healing it's inflamed yeah keep the well
so here we go
yeah I'm after I have something to say
Wow
natural is [ __ ] dude back in a day a
couple years ago on JK news I was so
against plastic surgery right but that's
because I'm surrounded by beautiful
people I never really in this room huh
all over the world
yes yeah I just wanted to hear that do
you want me to say everybody except you
know I wanted I wanted you to say me
don't I'm gonna give you a little bit of
I gotta do that you caught me okay I
Maggie I'm gonna give little bits of
compliment but don't [ __ ] take it all
in like that just wait don't [ __ ] get
on it all right all right let me get
back to my [ __ ] statement right
three years ago or two years ago or
whatever I used to be highly against
plastic surgery set girls you are
beautiful the way are I said all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's because I'm
around people that are good-looking this
yes I agree
I look at [ __ ] like this and I go [ __ ]
man I know I didn't think about the ugly
girls in the world what about them they
need against plastic
but lightweight though this girl she's
not hideous though she look like she
grows daikon for a living it's [ __ ]
radish former to kpop star
she lost the way to dude that's some
great [ __ ] it says a lot that you need
surgery to look a ver egde that's a
thing so a lot of people are saying like
a lot of women in South Korea and in
China they're just striving for
uniformity because everyone just looks
the same now that's what I hear they're
striving for uniformity so they want to
look like everyone else that's what like
this one article head writer said that I
would tell ya they're all looking to say
look at the sixth one like the truth oh
my god this one I actually can't tell
which one's worse I both look okay that
one looks like a pop psych a Chinese pop
star and then the other one looks like
don't they both look like pop star she
look like she got a job I think her
feeling me right here
she's not ugly she looks average yeah
but if this [ __ ] add some makeup to her
she look pretty [ __ ] banging and Plus
what if she's naked you don't even put
that factor in either yeah come on now
yeah she's definitely not ugly good next
one
yep whoa [ __ ] but Co nah she look Wow Oh
amazing word with crazy huh yo that is
3d guys you guys know this person that
used to be my video guy and he has a
cousin looks just like this yeah I
hadn't seen that [ __ ] in like four
years which so she first came to America
saw her at a wedding of a mutual friend
of ours [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I couldn't
recognize her she looked like this she
look like the other one words she wasn't
she wasn't crazy but she looks exactly
like this Wow but you loved all the
views no to look for that girl yes
yeah even their skin tone is different
everybody got like bleaching or
something
see this is why I agree I am
are gonna say I'm against plastic
surgery if you can come from Shrek to a
[ __ ] you serve your good friends have
had it me and Gino I don't care
does this boobies I'm always I've always
been for boobies I've never I never saw
it to save that's synagogue surgery this
is plastic surgery plastic in your face
yep restructuring yeah you know you
don't change identities you need a
[ __ ] certificate for movies this one
it's [ __ ] it's like a twenty four
twenty five dollar one hour massage lady
and also a pop star she also looks like
she went from about thirty-six to about
twenty-two yeah you know thirty six
years old you know good right here she
looks like she works at one of those
Cape time Kate on late-night eat the
place yeah like the Chinese armwrestling
jab you know she works like she works
she was she looks like she's kind of
tough she went from macro factory what
the [ __ ] you're the one making the jokes
if you would go oh hell no I'm already
cute enough as it is I'm good a six too
[ __ ] cute ass girl what the huh you
know what you it's only from the neck up
right so her face looks like this but
underneath she looks like she powerless
for a living oh yeah I don't need
plastic surgery I just need to hit the
gym what I think the gym did when all
this look you need a [ __ ] miracle
really yeah but you only she'd be like a
minute distant cousin of mine yeah I
don't know I don't give a [ __ ] what
people want to do is their own life
their own business I think that's cool
the only time I'm like damn you should
have thought about it a little bit is
when you start having kids and then your
kids look like a [ __ ] up you that's
the only time for me this lady she's not
hideous enough requests would have you
seen these makeup artists but they were
[ __ ] a magic so I think I don't think
she's hideous in that first time so even
with that
was where this girl she looked like an
ogre like her she had like a extended
lower jaw her I understand because her
face seriously looked like somebody took
a sledgehammer to a [ __ ] cuz her jaw
stopped performing after the age of
seven no no no this girl had an extended
lower Java she looked like the old
McDonald's moon man oh my god she looked
like a like a [ __ ] Bulldog yeah
Mac's an Italian plastic surgery before
after and you'll find her picture
immediately because she's one of the
first ones her I understand because it
looks like [ __ ] insane yes surgery go
with someone you know the one I'm
talking about well no way I'm not sure
but she there was a before and after of
this lady here and she looks like a
mixed martial arts fighter
that's insane I'm happy that girls
aren't superficial because we could be
ugly as [ __ ] we just need money oh wow
oh are you serious yeah very much no not
you know I'm not sure because I saw
before and after it was an actual
official website of somebody like this
that a guy Shane of gosh she looks like
a samurai warrior oh I think I know
which one you're talking about those
David cuz like there is a female that
looks very similar but she doesn't look
bad this wasn't her after pic it was
this one right here I'm sorry son this
one no yeah I think the bottom line is
here what you say if you saw a side
picture of her she actually has a like
extended lower jaw it was like look like
this she's doing ugly though and Real
Talk you're always someone is always
gonna find you ugliest [ __ ] true yeah
but you know they don't want me to Yoker
they want the top-notch men handsome
good and rich and everything like once
they look like this yeah I mean either
in reality if you want if you want guys
like that you gotta look lesser wait now
am i right no because you could have a
[ __ ] ugly ass personality yeah but
those guys are superficial there's a lot
of got oh she's that's it Wow don't like
a big guy oh yeah there's guys who did
it - wow you found the smallest picture
in the world why does he look like my
old Korean
character parking hey that's not right
the guy that looks like me man he's just
the hairs like that
you should never change you're good the
way you were but the girls that the
team's huh what's up guys how do we do
did you like it did you hate it well
guess what there's only a like button
and if you liked it that's the way to
communicate that to us so make sure to
hit that like button and for more
episodes click right above me
[Music]